today marks 100 years since one of the
worst
acts of racial violence in our country's
history the black
wall street massacre in tulsa oklahoma
between may 31st
and june 1st of 1921 tulsa's prosperous
african-american community known as
black wall street was attacked
planes even flew overhead dropping
explosives in a matter of hours the area
was demolished
more than 1200 homes and businesses were
destroyed
the vernon ame church is the only
building that survived the massacre
the original basement is still intact in
fact and it's where people hid from the
white mob
if you can imagine just being in here
100 years ago hearing the bombs go off
hearing women crying baby screaming and
you not knowing of your neck
hundreds were killed they were dumped in
mass graves
survivors rounded up and taken to
internment camps then deputized
by as white men by white men at beggar
pardon
later survivors filed more than a
million dollars in insurance claims and
they were all denied
no one was ever prosecuted or punished
for the massacre
tonight at 10 o'clock cbs this morning
anchor gayle king is hosting tulsa 1921
in american tragedy
that'll be right here on channel 8. the
special features
stories from survivors descendants and
historians well worth watching